Speaker 1: We are now approaching thirty thousand.
We're like one hundred and something two hundred
away from thirty thousand subscribers to The
David Pakman Show sub Reddit, one of the most
subscribed independent progressive media sub.
It's four shows hosted by lefthanded Argentinean
Jews.
Among that category we have the biggest sub
Reddit, which is an incredible achievement.
A few interesting discussions I found this
morning on the sub Reddit.
A lot of people trying to sign up for not
Mike Pillow, Michael and Dell's new sort of
a social media platform.
Frank speech, people unable to sign up, user
EFM and rules said, trying to sign up to Mike
Pelo Twitter wannabee.
All I get is a syntax or server error.
Yeah, we talked about this a little bit on
the bonus show yesterday and I believe we
may be scheduled to talk about it again again
today.
It's it's hilarious.
I am really taking pleasure in the complete
failure of the Mike Pelo frank speech, Twitter,
Twitter wannabee.
But I've heard from a couple of people who
say they were able to sign up.
I don't know how, because the website seems
to be persistently down, but a true comedy
of errors taking place with frank speech dot
com.
I'll even take a look at it now, see if I
can pull up the website.
Oh, they've put they've set up didas protection
and yeah, there's nothing.
They claim to have received over two billion
requests in two days now.
A lot of it is those a lot of those two billion
are are deliberate, repeated attempts to take
down the website.
It's a massive success, even though no one
can use it or sign up.
OK, so that's what's happening on Frank Frank
speech.
Dotcom user, Tabasco.
Dan commented on when people call into the
show and said, what is the point of David
taking calls if it always seems like he wants
to strangle them, unless, of course, they're
from Europe, then he wants to see where they've
had lunch, even if the connection sounds like
they're calling from a nuclear submarine.
Here's what I have to say about this.
The fact that this viewer admits that often
the calls sound like people are calling from
a submarine vindicates my frustration with
the call quality.
But as I've said before, most people we've
actually studied this.
Most people like the calls as an occasional
thing.
The people that don't are really loud about
it and sometimes even threatened to cancel
their subscription altogether when they could
just skip that 10 minute segment on Fridays.
But but it's a combination of comedy.
And I want to hear from the people.
I do want to hear from the people.
Lastly, here is a Reddit post about the YouTube
recommendations.
This is the experience of one viewer who says
YouTube recommendations are out of control,
literally on every video, on every device,
whether on VPN or not, whether signed in or
not.
I go out of my way to not watch right wingers
for any reason, even to criticize or just
out of curiosity of what Fox News propaganda
is blasting.
No matter the topic, there is always at least
one right wing recommendation.
This never used to happen, at least not as
much.
Maybe there's an upswing of right wing outrage
going viral now that they actually have something
to complain about.
Biden is in power so they can do the old Obama
communist routine.
Seriously, I've been recommended to Daily
Caller videos when I've been signed into YouTube,
which I watch David Pakman, Stephen Colbert,
etc., pretty much as far away from the alt
right trampas as you can get.
Oh yeah.
Also Reddit recommended me the Steven Crowder
sub Reddit because it was similar to this
one.
Is it really that hard for these algorithms
to distinguish what type of politics?
Let me ever see any left wing content recommended
on YouTube to anyone.
That sentence is a doozy.
Hold on.
Let me ever see any left wing content recommended
on YouTube to anyone anyway.
The point is, as they point out here, conservatives
complain about being censored when these algorithms
are basically affirmative action for them.
Whether it's deliberate or accidental doesn't
matter if you two proudly displays empowering
women when literally every video has a feminazi
destroyed video, you know, it's complete B.S..
All right.
The sentiment there that there's a lot of
people being fed, a lot of right wing drivel
on YouTube, Reddit and other platforms is
absolutely true.
And frequently I hear from people who say,
David, I only watch you and other left wing
shows.
And YouTube keeps pushing me to Steven Crowder
and Ben Shapiro and all of this other stuff.
It seems to be happening.
Joined the discussion at David Pakman dotcom
slash Reddit, where we have almost 30000 sub
Reddit subscribers